today's topic if i'm a stepdad for a
white kid
i'm not going to share my black culture
are you going to do the same you saw my
face
your face was like you this will happen
this is what happened yeah i was not
there with you but i just saw your face
and this will happen you were not really
listening
and probably watching the game yeah
and then this [ __ ] was hold up it would
what the [ __ ] did you say to me that
that's what happened you could bring it
back
but you you you just
you didn't comprehend metal gear solid
what what
that was what happened
that is the most iconic video game
about if i'm a step-dad for a white kid
i'm not gonna share my black culture
are you gonna do the same
oh
that was beautiful it was instant it was
great
and then i can wait but it's the way you
look at him
after there's the first initial what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah because he's part of the big
forehead tribe i'm not gonna share my
black culture
are you gonna do the same
what
is
it's not even and if after that the look
you gave him listen
it went from bad to worse you went
that's
number one what that was number two
and then you look the eye that's number
three and fourth level is when you leave
what if your stepdad to a white kid
so meaning like if you have a girlfriend
and she's white
and she have a kid with her are you
going to share your black culture
because you're going to be the stepdad
so usually as a stepdad you want to
share your culture but
me i was just talking and i'm like no
hell no i'm not going to share my black
culture like this is mine and
this is your kid so i want to see if you
guys like agree
since you know you're black man and it
could happen give me an example of
something you wouldn't share
me you already know
i know you you know what you were
thinking
good content we got to make some money
oh this is good like wow
this is going it's crazy what i'm
african so imagine like
to go to so you're not gonna let her eat
your people's food
i'm not gonna be the one who's gonna
share that if she wanna use it or
go get it like she can do it herself but
i'm not gonna be the one like
sharing this what the [ __ ] did the kid
do to you so
you're not the one that's gonna share
that maybe she's gonna find another
[ __ ] from your friend the tribe that's
gonna be able to share that
bro and much more i said the food part
jokingly
no and he was real real hey babe where
are you going
off to eat some couscous can i come no
[ __ ] no go
my [ __ ] only me and my [ __ ] eat the
couscous
but i'm gonna eat the poo spoons later
see ya yes
yeah she can't not eat the couscous and
have her poop
eaten oh
moving mad past that you want to be a
stepfather to somebody
you want to have them be in your
household and live by some of your
values but you don't want to share your
culture with them
then why would you take on the
responsibility of bringing them under
your umbrella
how does that make any sense i don't
understand this kind of language it's
like
i think i think a lot of people feel
very conflicted about interracial dating
and so they say a lot of this goofy
stuff none of this makes any sense
i want to preserve my culture then you
marry someone from your culture that's
how you preserve it the best way
possible
you don't go to marry other people from
other cultures not share with them and
think
if you're not passing it down through
your kids in your next gene pool
through your wife to make sure that your
kids properly assimilated
your culture is not going to be
preserved it's going to die with you
that's it that's how it functions right
there's a reason why a lot of folks from
other cultures
encourage dating within that culture is
for those
habits and that culture to pass down
effectively through both parents
are you going to take her to eat your
people's food yeah that's a good
question
exactly that me not so what you just
going to have burgers with her and eat
her people's food
yeah i would maybe go more into her
culture and stay with her culture but
maybe i'll
i'll keep my culture to myself and why
would you date a girl
seriously who you don't want to share
your culture with
me i'm trying to make calculations right
there me i'm trying to put the
mathematics and i'm not even really good
at mathematics so this got me [ __ ] up
it got me [ __ ] up all the way [ __ ]
up nothing can stop me i'm all the way
[ __ ] up like it was it was
it was it was i was trying to and then
he was coming with some more [ __ ] that i
was like bruh
what huh it makes me laugh like if
you're going to complain about cultural
appropriation and you don't want to
encourage it
why would you date and try to marry
somebody i don't understand
just go with people from your culture
it's not that complicated
you know what i'm saying i still
you know what let me just press play you
say it better than i could
once again this is from our instagram
lives we do a lot of conversations with
fans so if you want to come
talk to us on camera follow us on
instagram and here comes the
conversations the spicy one
this is the thing it's kind of
interesting just thinking about this you
know like
i'm a second generation right and then
if she's white for myself my
my generation like the culture for me i
want to keep it for myself
i mean at the end of the day is the
person that's your significant other
it's like you're trying to be pro-black
by and still later white girl
i mean yeah that's what i'm saying you
know i mean you tried the data
that is exactly what i was thinking
you want to be oo mark johnson and seal
okay it's like pick one
you can't kiss from the road and then
and then also be like
it's got to be a dark roast sorry not
this is what your website
listen listen this is the most confusing
nonsense i heard it was great that was
great but you can't just
be like remove the burden of all of that
of you dating a white girl or are you
dating whoever you want
i thought you were raised by being i'm
not going to share my culture that's not
how it works
none of it works like that nothing works
like that
i feel like for me this is like about
woke points
yeah it's like yeah i'm dating a black
girl but i haven't sold out you know
what i'm saying like i i still put that
[ __ ] in her place
she tried to eat couscous i'm like no
you can't no
no and you know what her little a little
pet name you know
she calls me boo boo i call her
colonialist
like no uh hey settler you can't
do that that it doesn't it's just it
makes it toxic
yeah it makes it toxic it's supposed to
be your significant other you're doing
that whole [ __ ] into a
significant other man it's not it's not
what it is it doesn't work like that can
you imagine
you're doing your vows getting married
for better or for worse and you're like
[ __ ] keep the blindfold on i don't want
you to see my
my family's wearing or eat any of their
food imagine having a wedding we're
having a wedding but
you're going to be at the other side of
the table because you're not part of
that culture
you and your wife it doesn't work like
that you're not making anything better
you're making
that's hella dysfunctional yeah
hella like umbrella ella ella super
dysfunctional yeah and that guarantees
that your step child will never accept
you no you try to hide
and keep them away from a huge part of
who you are um and then what happened if
you have a kid
with that lady that has a step child so
you're going to keep the late
the step child away oh no that's my son
you
you a white [ __ ] but that's why like i
said man
i think a lot of people don't know how
to feel about interracial dating
they want to have their cake and eat it
too they want to
feel some type of way about white folks
but then also be able to date them with
a clear conscience i'm saying
you gotta go to therapy you gotta have a
conversation with yourself
searching to do bro yeah come you they
can't do that
yeah it doesn't put me in a better place
than anybody but
know where things come from there's
nothing i could do
that whenever people say talk [ __ ] to me
i'm like yeah i know where that's from
and i know where you got that hate
but it's not like no no no no you can't
talk to me like that
because yeah that's my wife but
i don't share with the white devil you
it doesn't
no you can't it sounds like you're the
part of you is ashamed to be with a
white person yes does you
does anybody want to be with someone who
feels ashamed to be with them
ugh that's gross you have to find out
why the reason
why you're doing this because the why is
very important to be fair to him there's
a lot of people who have weird views
about interracial dating you still do it
you know there's people from like asian
families who will have a black boyfriend
but will never bring them home
because of how it looks you gotta sort
that [ __ ] out you gotta figure that out
you gotta prioritize yourself a lot of
people have to have some discussions
love is love no it's more complicated
than unfortunately
trust me bro yeah when you have a father
curse john say he's going to kill you if
you see a dog it's not just love is love
it's complicated it's complicated so
people got to sort their [ __ ] out but
this was weird
this was hella weird this was someone
who was coping
you know it's like it's like someone
who's heard about the sunken place
that is in the sunken place but denies
that they're in the sunken place
like they're aware of its existence you
know what i mean they're deep in it
but they're like some [ __ ] happened it's
like [ __ ] we watch
through an aquarium you deep in there
some [ __ ] happens yay
no no no this is like the plot for the
movie get out
it's like you watched the movie get out
and still fell into the trap
you know what i'm saying confusion
that's all i got to say anything else
you want to say i feel for the dude
because that's that's that's my homie
i know the dude i actually know him but
i was like bro what are you saying
no no what are you saying and you know i
know the dude and i still have to give
it to him
hey you can't do that you come on the
live
i could know no it doesn't matter i had
as i dated yeah
come on the live talking some nonsense i
booted them off yeah but i'm not
mid-sentence no no but we
are we are comparing with our [ __ ] come
on that [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna get what you're gonna get
you're gonna get with a lot people are
gonna say stuff
you're gonna read the comments it's that
that's what it is and we're gonna
if you say some nonsense you're going to
get it whether we know you're not we're
going to be fair with that we're not
going to give it
nobody privileges we don't get no pain
no privileges no
white privilege no black privilege we're
all equal in this [ __ ] yeah unless
you're really hot then you get an extra
30 seconds
okay i don't mind staring us and hitting
me as
beauty privilege so if you guys want to
see some more hit us up on ig
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below what did you guys think
about this conversation we want to hear
from you
[Music]
play